this is a production of Cornell
University
thank you yipping for the introduction
so again there is the title of the
presentation I'm very honored to be here
and thank you for the invitation and for
you to be
um here sitting today to hear what I
have to tell you
um
I think you've been already covered this
part so um
I have my background in forestry
breathing
um I worked there for a few years on
that and then I was the pi for forage
breeding for the forest reading program
at the University of Florida for a few
years and then nowadays I'm working in
blueberry breathing when I was working
in forages I started the
um
basically the research of polyploid
species because I was working mainly
with Alfalfa as a research model in that
moment
and then when I started working with
blueberries you know it translated very
nicely because both these species are
output tetraploid so I'll be telling you
a little bit about that today
but today in the main you know
species that we're going to be referring
to or talking to uh and the one that I'm
using as a model is uh High Bush
blueberry right and this is vaccine in
Korean boss
so during the talk I I hope to
convince you that this is a good species
that is an important species and then
actually you should be eating
blueberries
um
and at the same time you know I'm gonna
tell you how the breathing happens in
the research that we are carrying about
uh carrying on to actually make it
faster better and more accurate right so
first let me tell you that the blueberry
production and consumption is increasing
rapidly nowadays I mean the U.S has
always been the number one consumer
blueberries globally
um and nowadays actually this is
outdated already but nowadays the per
capita consumptions of blueberries here
in the U.S is 2.75 pounds per person
right and then the production keeps
increasing as
the industry has created a year-round
availability of blueberries in the
supermarket which I'm sure that you guys
have seen there is more consumption and
that creates you know more production
and then it goes on and on
this is sold you know
um boosted or um kind of with the label
of blueberries are good for you right
getabusa blue you know eat healthy eat
blue right
um
so it's a pretty important specie for us
you know it's a very big industry
globally nowadays now for the breathers
and I think this is very important uh if
you're a breather this is the things
that probably you want to know right
away
so we have a perfect flower easy hand
pollination an advantage those are the
good things right relative short cross
to fruit time so I'm gonna
um
dimitify that there is a shortly you
know even when it's a perennial fruit
species
the varietal type that we breed we can
get fruit in one year
a difference of other
um fruity species or or the uh blueberry
that's grown here in the north and I'm
gonna go there in a sec many seeds or
progeny per cross that's a pretty nice
right an advantage
um we can clearly propagate it very nice
and we then cuttings to propagate and at
the same time we use tissue culture of
course now the bad things in breathing
depression that's about things for us
it's highly heterozygous which is good
and in reality you know I don't believe
that we understand very well still that
level of heterozygosity that exists in
polyploid species and how that affects
very well the expression but I'll I'll
go there in a second later and it's an
auto
polyploid specifically and that creates
some challenges that I'll be discussing
as well
blueberry is only one of the very few
species that actually was domesticated
here in the US
very very few I think there is only like
three to four species that now are
consumed globally that actually was
domesticated here in the U.S and this
happened just in 1910 around 1910 I
don't want to be uh exact with the date
and then uh it's not exactly the river
around 1910 the great breakthrough
happens and I was talking with GP in
early about this
when the researchers discovery that
actually was acid soil that was needed
in reality to to to grow the plant you
know to manage it otherwise you know you
could not get a vigorous plant and you
could not get enough flu varies so all
the plants that they were transplanting
from the wild actually were dying
because the soils were no acid enough
and that was the Breakthrough moment and
it's amazing how something you know so
um insignificant if you think about all
the technology everything that we do it
has it can have such a big impact
actually that that was the point of
investigation that happened it happened
so a few years ago in terms of
domestication that we have the whole
track of the history of the
domestication as I'm telling you right
now and even we have all the pedigaries
associated with the domestication
nowadays we spend like five years
carrying the
um
um Discovery or
covering the pedigree of of the whole
crop and now we have around you know 16
000 lines of pedigree in our pedigree in
our breeding program
now this is species that was
domesticated here it couldn't be grown
in the south
right because it has high chill
requirements so anybody that works with
fruits you will understand uh that
concept right
so uh researchers in the 1950s start the
efforts to cross in this uh Northern
High Bush that we call it right we're
native species of the South to create
the hybrid that nowadays we know as the
southern high bush
so still this Southern High bush is a
vaccine occur in Boston so botanically
but in reality
genetically or genomically I call it
this a potpourri of genomes
right it has no juice uh this vaccine
and Roi
um in the genome but in reality has
other five or six species that have been
used through the history of the
breathing from the 50s up to today's so
it's a potpourri of genomes in reality
okay
but that's the main species that I'm
referring to today and then I'll be
discussing about
these two species I mean that's the
first question that you're probably
going to be thinking about how different
are are they right so the Northerns from
the Southerns so this is a
PCA very simple PCA used in around 29
different quality fruit quality traits
and then uh just to show you that you
know even when one is derived from the
other they are very differently uh in
the way that they they they express
their trade so here we have in blue the
Northern High Bush and this is a
population of around 1 000 individuals
from Oregon and then we have uh from
Oregon breeding program and then we have
the southern high bush in red which is
the breeding population around 1 000
individuals from our program as well so
that's uh very interesting for us and
this is very fresh this is using
phenotypic data but we are genotyping
all these populations as part of one of
the cap projects that we have
so with the domestication or the
adaptation of this new varietal type to
the South
now there was the expansion you know of
of growth and production in the South
but not just that in reality that helped
significantly to the expansion to the
global expansion as well of um
blueberries in tropical and subtropical
areas
and nowadays for more breathing program
at least we license to 14 or 17
different countries
um
in every single year as I as I'm going
to be showing you and we work with many
different uh companies and producers
around the globe
um
the program has developed many cultivars
since the origin of the program since
the beginning right and this is just to
show you that um is this is not just
history this is a very active breeding
program and then almost every year we
have the capacity to release one to two
cultivars because we have a very
established Pipeline and given that we
work globally with different producers
there is always need for one of our
cultures somewhere
um and just to show you you know more or
less how they look this is one that
actually I just uh release uh this year
now what is the impact that plant
breeding has had in in this species and
this is used again to
you know prove you somehow to that thumb
breathing can have a big impact in the
domestication and in the uh Improvement
of of blueberries as a crop so here we
have the firmness of the fruit in the
y-axis on the x-axis we have the year of
release of the cultivar so each of these
dots here is one culture so we did track
all the cultivars and every piece of
information that exists about the
firmness of the fruit and obviously
through the history has been
um quantifying different ways we try to
standardize as much as we could right
and then we see in red the northern
height which the regionally domesticated
and then we see in blue the southern
high Bush the ones that we work with
and
as you see there is a huge increase and
it's starting around the 1970s uh 90
between 70s and 80s a huge increase in
the firmness of the fruit product of the
breathing efforts that they were
happening in different places right now
we see a larger increase or a more steep
increase in the case of the Southern
High bush
and that will be probably easy to
understand after what I'm gonna tell you
so in the case of Southern High bush
they are replaced Faster by The
Producers because they don't survive as
long as they do the Northern High Bush
here in the northern part of the country
right
just this summer I was in Michigan in a
planting
that was established 70 years ago
right
and actually the blueberry variety that
they were used it was one of the
original ones that comes from here the
ones that actually was extracted
directly from the wild so it was kind of
a
domesticated uh plan that they're still
we're using to produce blueberries right
so if that happened you as a breather
what is the incentive to release your
cultures they don't get adopted right
now because the southern ones they last
a lot a lot less right around 10 to 15
years there is always need to be
replacing them right so whenever the
grower makes a decision to replace them
obviously it's going to choose whatever
is best and whatever is available right
so that's the main difference I would
say
nowadays the breathing program is
probably I will say almost almost the
way I wanted to run it right
um
we do have four stages of fire stages if
you can see the cultivar uh release part
right as the product development and we
go through different stages from all the
way whenever we do the crossings and we
germinate around maybe 200 000 seedlings
um all the way to 20 plants established
in multi-state Trials
um and then also in different states
in uh to release one or two cultivars
per year
this process is being carried out for
the last 30 35 years without stopping
every single year this happens so
whenever I come into this program and
what you see here there is a lot of
changes little changes in the logistic
you know uh most probably students are
going to think that
the biggest things that you can do in a
breathing program is just put technology
and make a huge change
a huge increase in the productivity in
the accuracy in the speed where in
reality I will argue that a lot of what
you need to do is to improve the
logistic of a program and everything
else is going to be
helping to make it better
um so in this process nowaday we use
molecular markers of course we use
genomic selection as well in operational
way for the last four years
um
and then we also use some metabolomics
um to decide what needs to be released
for the consumer
we are fortunate that we have a huge
diversity and this is what I call the
blue Universe right uh
and then the trees that we're still
exploring this because I don't know if
you have ever seen you know this very
beautiful upload of the pedigree of
Pioneer in the past and now the cortiva
right where you have the different
erotic groups uh beautiful right and
then they know very well you know what
you need to cross to exploit that
aterosity
hopefully one day we can we can get
there right it will take them some time
to untangle this mess I would say but
for now we are good we have good
diversity to keep moving forward
now
now let's talk a little bit about the
research and how what are the tools and
what are the things that we used to to
do research right
so mainly us trained genomeses and
quantity geneticists I will say that the
main things that we do and then I'm
excluding here rna-seq and all the other
things that potentially we could be
using
are these uh three different things here
so
you know qtl analysis
very structured populations right that
you create you create the recombination
but in the other end you have genetic
genetic Association or G was analysis
hopefully with a very
um
high resolution if you do have the
number of individuals and the number of
markers to cover that genome right
and I will say that in the middle you
know is it something that um
is very practical for us
because
genomic wise selection or genomic
selection or genomic prediction whatever
you guys want to call it right
is a methodology that was proposed to
this to be used in population
semi-structured populations I would say
right
there is benefit to using qt in in
populations as a structures at qtl or by
parental populations
I will argue that yes uh and then
probably you cannot use it in in
diversity panels because you don't have
the structure that you need to track
where you need to track there okay and
we can argue about that and we can
discuss at the end of the day all this
depends on linkage linkage
disequilibrium or the size of the
linkage blog is going to tell you what
tool you should be using and how do you
move forward without this strategy you
know so if I know in this very well you
can decide what can you move
operationally and what what the studies
do you need actually to find markers to
be used in the breeding program
now the biggest challenge and this is
going to be very surprising if any of
you uh does any quantity genetics or
have estimated any heritabilities or
anything like that the biggest challenge
for us actually when I start working in
polyploid species is that you could not
even build a matrix what is called the
numerator numerator Matrix numerator
relationship Matrix or the um
relationship Matrix kinship Matrix in
reality you know this is twice the
kinship Matrix it gives you the
relationship Matrix right
it was not possible to do so one of the
first things that we did back in
2015 we started working on this is
actually to develop a free package so
everybody could do it no you saso that's
the first thing obviously we did it for
our needs but then we realized it was
needed to be used for everybody because
there was nothing like that in that
moment actually there was one single
software that cost like I think it was
fifteen thousand dollars per year and it
came from Australia so I I'm not gonna
say there was nothing there was a
software you just need to pay a lot of
money to use it
um so we built a free one right
um nowadays this software handles any
employee
pedigree genomics or both included
additive dominance and epistasis there
is 13 different methodologies in in
there so you choose what do you want to
use depending on what do you one and
also it handles you know continuous
genotyping which is going to be
something I'm going to be discussing in
a sec
is an issue at that moment imagine I
mean we're starting this work and there
was not even a way to build the
relationship Matrix to calculate to
estimate heritabilities and then to
predict reading values which is my
training so I that's the first thing I
want to do in a breathing program
predict bringing values to see what I
need to cross on how do I need to move
the program forward so we couldn't even
use it right so ploid is an issue
was an issue and then um you know you
have here that the in a graphical way
how you can represent this right so you
have counts of one allele accounts of
the second allele the alternative allele
and then each of these dots represent
one individual right so and eventually
here is a pretty uh pretty plot that
says you know how many doses so you have
from each of these individuals alleles
right
um and then you can fit this nice models
there is like six or seven different
models that actually we fit uh to find
out in a g was or in a genomic selection
as well you can fit them in whatever I
mean if you know what you are doing you
can fit in whatever way you want it
right but actually whenever you are
feeding these different models obviously
you are asking a different question
right so it depends of the hypothesis
that you are you have behind now the
issue is that this is very messy it's
never as pretty as this right and then
um
one of the things that we worked on I
don't think I put that here nope uh for
the operational use again I was trained
in this area we needed to use markers to
optimize a lot of the things that we
need to optimize so basically the way
that we went okay we use this software
that we have developed
we could call the dosage or deployee as
I was mentioning before but then we did
some studies and work actually to
demonstrate that we can use continuous
genotyping basically the ratio of one
allele to the other
in order to use in the prediction models
and that was you know published in this
paper uh sometime in 2019.
um so with that we solved one of the
issues I mean by that time there is many
softwares that you could use to call
ploidy but in reality none of them were
were very accurate and even nowadays I
will argue that it still is a mess
because of um it's not very it's not
very clean
the the the calling of the of the ploidy
so then we impute that dosage of ratio
in in some of the softwares and then we
evaluate different things for the
Practical use of the molecular markers
in the breeding program again and
nowadays you know we use that
operationally
and then we went obviously to a phase of
the optimization of this molecular
markers and populations because
again genomic selection Works genomic
prediction works I mean it's not a
matter of it works or not you know and
um and I always like to discuss this
with the students you know it's not a
matter of you are going to test it to
see if it works it works why you need to
optimize is the population that you are
using and how to integrate that in the
breeding program
right
um so we went through a whole phase of
optimization of that uh of four
populations and or molecular markers and
the way that we did it in order to have
a way to apply it uh operationally and
nowadays actually in this very moment we
are going through a second phase of
optimization to try to make it even
better cheaper and faster
so with that way we could decrease you
know the traditional pipeline of around
12 to 15 years actually to to develop uh
cultivars to
um you know roughly have in reality
seven to eight years we can release a
cool fever nowadays a lot of logistics
improve not just genomic selection
now
now we have the capacity to get breeding
values so what do you do with them and
then I I will argue the second and very
very important phase is actually to know
whether you need to be crossing right so
in this stage a few years ago we started
to uh creating optimization but in
reality you know there is a very nice
software that was released by our
friends in Edinburgh
um
and then in our case we do 100 crosses
so this is the argument 100 crosses
every year right and we use we try to
use every single plant alive to see what
it needs to be crossed in for the Next
Generation right
uh so roughly we use only one of the
stage two we have four stage two three
stage twos at every single time so we
have around 8 000 plants in a stage two
every single year but let's say that we
use the newest one on so plus all the
other individuals from stage three is
four cultivars and some of the wild
species back crosses that we have
um there is about four million possible
crosses that we can carry right
because we do 100 so there's virtual
Infinity number of 100 groups that you
can get out of these four thousand
million uh four million uh possible
crosses right so
graphically I'm very graphic to see what
we need to do right so we have one
single trade this is firmness of the
fruit
we have the diversity
of the population given by the
relationship Matrix across all these
individuals that we have in the
population
so then you have this Cloud so each of
these dots is a potential cross that you
can make right
and this is the breathing the plant
breather you know problem you know how
to maximize gain
without compromising diversity in your
reading program and you want to be there
right so this is an optimization problem
right and being an optimization problem
the solution is always going to be in
the border right so the thing is how do
you navigate to get there
right and then again or friends in um
you know in Edinburgh we're able to
release these these software's Alpha
made but basically you know explored the
um
the statistical space basically the
vectorial space to get to the optimum
and then to decide which process you
need to make nowadays we have optimized
I mean a customized our own Optimizer
because this was made originally for
cattle of course for animals where they
have been doing this a lot longer than
we are so we have different restrictions
in the optimization problem that we need
to
um we need to input impute in the in the
in the equation in reality and that's
why we have to create our own and there
is still a lot of work to do in this in
reality but this is used to give you an
idea
now
let's talk a little bit about in that
time again we're talking about whenever
you know this ploidy was not very
resolved yet a few you know five six
seven years ago
people was fit in still deployed models
into the tetraploid data right so then
we asked the question okay can you do
that without compromising the results so
then we whatever tools that we have in
those days we fit with deep uh
tetraploid choline and or genomic data
and then deploy choline and then we did
this comparison and find out as it makes
sense of course because it's nature
right if you fit tetraploid models they
work better right again in that time you
know again this happens a few years ago
it was not that
logic or that I mean it was logic but
there was a lot of challenges to call
deployee right
now
where am I going here because I mean I
went from prediction and apply an
operational use of genomic data and to
try to find some function here right on
some markers that actually we can also
use in the breathing program
and the idea behind here is because
there is already been a lot of
information that
uh prior to this work of course
um
um for for a long time already that the
use of biological information in our
genomic selection or genomic prediction
models will help the model to achieve
higher accuracy right so at that moment
you realize okay then we need to find
out what biological information can fit
in our mode so this is just an example
that we have different populations here
and we fit different models to and we
achieve different levels of accuracies
right so yes it helps
now another of the big very big things I
mean I'm being very fortunate that I
mean the time point when actually a lot
of resources are being created so we get
to test them and then evaluate you know
the capacity that these resources have
to improve the work that we are doing
this is a very simple paper I mean if
you're a student in breathing I would
just recommend you to read these two
three pages right but it tells you
exactly what is here how a quality
genome can improve what we do as
breeders right and then it talks about
very briefly about how genomic selection
can be improved how optimization of the
markers can be improved
um
and then in this case for the G was
analysis
before without a genome there is no way
to order this of course you know so what
do you get out of here what is your
inference
not the trade is quantitative and it's
everywhere right there is signal
everywhere and obviously after the
genome you know it's like beautiful this
is the same trait before and after uh
when we were doing this
um
when I start working and we didn't have
a genome and again it's it's not very
long Geno it's not very big genome 600
megabase more or less
um and I came from pine trees remember I
told you before pine trees is a monster
of a genome and still they are not able
to assemble
and then we have done many studies in
the past with pine trees and we found
this many times it's like okay
everything is quantitative right there
is no way and nowadays still they don't
have a way to get to this point so it's
very relevant so I will say I will argue
that if you are in the point that you
can influence if a genome if you're in
your species of work you don't have a
genome yet it's worth to to do it I know
many of you probably are working on
species they are not considered orphan
as this one nowadays not anymore
um so maybe you are way past this this
period
so we do a lot of G was analysis uh in
our program
and then
or research associate Felipe ferraroi
has a GitHub where it has all the
information of how we do it and
everything so if you want to explore
that uh you are welcome to to to do that
but just to give you an idea because
again remember that we do a lot of
genomic selection operationally but at
the same time
uh we have a lot of students that are
carrying different projects for
different questions and then we get to
accumulate a lot of data so it's been
very nice for us to discover or to ask
many questions and this is all the
different traits that we're exploring
and the class and then how many data
points so for the main trades that are
being used for uh breeding blueberries
we have around 7 000 data points that we
use and nowadays we have pretty good
idea of where the signals coming from
the genome for each of them
um
and at the same time because we do a lot
of G was we have explored a lot of
different ways to do it right so
um I'm gonna be showing you a few of the
unpublished we're in the process of of
of working these things out and to
validate some of them of different
methodologies and strategies that we are
trying to use actually to improve the
finding that signal that sometimes is is
hidden there right
so for example
uh multilocus Bayesian instead of the
traditional Q Plus K methodology right
what is this
basically just something like genomic
selection for the ones that know right
so it's USA mixed model with a model
selection in inserted in it so then you
feed all the markers simultaneously and
try to find the signal and it makes a
lot of sense that there is a lot of
shrinkage in the markers and then
hopefully the ones that are here are
just the ones that carry probably most
of the signal now in the past
I start working in genomic selection in
2011 a 12 more or less we tried this
many times again but it was a pine
genome so we could not find we could not
resolve that uh as we can do it today
given that we have much cleaner data and
then we asked some of those questions so
it's very nice we are in the process of
exploring if this for through these
values here carry the larger signal or
not and then we can use them for uh the
reading program
another one that probably some of you
have hear about it I mean this is not
new neither so these are just different
methods that we are exploring
um again we have the Q Plus K
methodology here traditional methodology
of a structure plus polygenic effect uh
in a millennial mixed model and then we
have the local methodology where the
local methodology basically what it does
is that it doesn't use the molecular
markers in the chromosome that you are
questioning
um to build the polygenic effect or the
relationship Matrix right so in that way
they get excluded of that and then again
we are able to find signal where there
was nothing before right now is it true
again or in the process of validating
all this one of the issues with the
local methodologies that create some
bias and then you will look at the QQ
plots and you will be like ah there's
something wrong here right
um but if the signal is true we don't
care how the QQ plots look right so from
the operational point of view
another one that is a very interesting
um
for us
it's actually
modify
the phenotype that you are using and
this will make a lot of sense after I
tell you that in reality where we call
firms I mean we decide what is firmness
right it's a trait that we are literally
they decide that that's fairness of the
trade
of the of the fruit right but
does it really matter if it's for
example in the fruit firm or the
firmness Tech or whatever methodology
you are using or or a box law
if is
70 or 50
why does it matter
right
well what we are trying to do here is to
find out what it matters for the
consumer
right what is that point
where the consumer it makes a difference
in the mouth of the consumers
below that
it doesn't matter you know because all
is the same
the consumer doesn't like it
above that the consumer likes it so then
basically you know you can just feed a
threshold model to find out what is that
point of inflection and in that point
you modify your phenotype and then you
ask the question okay is there any
marker associated with this point of
inflection
you get more power because at the end of
the day you know this
this methodologies they are kind of
setting an experiment the more
repetitions you have the more power
you're gonna have right so in this case
you know you increase the number of uh a
decrease the number of treatments uh all
the other all the genotypes they have to
fall into this uh two treatments only
right below or under and then
fortunately
he gave us better signal more power and
very strong signals now again we are in
the process of validating I'm sorry that
I don't have more progress for you at
this point on this
so using all this information
um we are being able to find out where
the signal comes from for different
trades for example fruit quality
or uh volatiles uh they are very
important for for us and I'll be talking
to you guys if I do have time about them
in a second
um and then some others that that's part
of this cup project I was mentioning
before also are going to be uh published
very soon
now as I mentioned in before
consumer for us is the most important
variable if you want to call it in the
breathing process right because at the
end of the day if the consumers eat more
fruit
you know the producer needs to produce
more more fruit the nursery needs to
produce more plants and we need to
produce more quality or so everybody's
happy right so that's kind of the
mentality and this is used as part of
this cap product you know an experiment
that we carry uh last year and then we
finish actually this year also the
willingness to pay uh related to overall
like you know the consumer experience in
these panels and then we see that these
are each of these dot is a different
culture and we see that you know
cultivars where the consumer has a
better experience is willing to pay more
money right makes sense
um
the issue is that
flavor or consumer experience a very
complex trade very very complex right
um
in
um I'm gonna be just defining flavor
very in a very simple way you know taste
whatever your tongue is able to
differentiate or sense right which is
sweet sour salty bitter and Umami right
and then whatever your receptors you
know in the bottom of your brain are
able to sense as well and these are the
volatile components these are the same
sensors that you use for orthonastal
smelling right so when you grab a
strawberry that's easy everybody has a
smelly strawberry right and you smell it
those are the same sensors that you're
going to be using the ones that I'm
gonna referring here is the one whenever
you mouth chew the food or fruit is in
every food right it's not specifically
for blueberries in every fruit and food
these volatiles go from the back of your
mouth and then go to the same sensors
right so simple will be fine that's with
the way we're going to Define flavor so
taste plus now the issue that is very
complex is very very complex an example
that I use all the time is I said
I want you to think in this moment about
the
you know the dish that your mom or your
grandma prepares and then in that moment
you start salivating if you really get
into thinking about that right
and in his amazing dish right
I can prepare the same dish and it could
be even better by you know by external
people and then I give it to you and
you're gonna say no my mom so my grandma
is better right it's because there is a
lot into psychology into the flavor
component right
um not just that so the experience the
culture and everything related so very
very complex in the case of blueberries
we were able to identify a lot of this
volatile organic compounds with many
studies and actually we have done a lot
more recently and then we know more or
less what label to assign to each of
them depending on what the companies uh
giving you regarding the experience
right
so we know they are very important and
then we have argued that the aroma
probably is or this volatile organic
compounds are one of the best candidates
for Market assistance selection
they have simple genetic architecture
they have larger readability and they
usually explain large variants
um and two of them for example very
important for us for blueberries
ordinolol that's a consumer enhancer we
have the program not just myself the
program has done research since 2012 on
this so we have a large data set of
Consumer Panel linked to biochemistry
volatiles and at the same time with
genomic data nowadays and then
eucalyptol for example while it might be
very good in other products uh it's not
good in blueberries you know people is a
deterrent of uh of liking
so we have used also some RNA seek to
validate some of these signals so it's
the first step so what do you do after
you find some signal you need to
validate it so validate your operational
and this is what I was showing here in
reality so an operational or in silica
validation by using different
populations and then finding out that
this trade is able to be predicted using
these molecular markers but also I mean
we are in research we are in a public
institution a part as part of what we do
we are trying to find also what is the
mechanism right because if we find the
council Genie will be a lot better for
using inner prediction models so we are
able to validate some of these candidate
genes but very important and then there
is Vincent
um this guy here is the main author of
this paper
um when he was in Florida we worked
together for a few years on this uh
probably longer than we wanted but at
the end of the day came through
um
the idea is that can we use all these
volatile information metabolite
information also to assess the consumer
partner and using again this large
historical data we're able to find out
that first the volatile organic
components are more important than the
traditional traits that are being
improved for 100 years which is sugars
and acid in the consumer acceptance or
consumer lower liking in tomato some
blueberries
um
and then those are the ones that want to
use very very briefly and I'm finishing
here these are the sugars and acids here
one of the cool things that we found out
that actually they were not very related
to all the other volatiles so while we
can improve volatiles we can improve
sugars and acid simultaneously without
having to
compete or having a negative correlation
which is very important for us
um
and at the same time you know some of
these volatiles give you some sensation
of Aroma know every volatile even they
they get captured through your olfature
system or sensors in the bottom of your
brain know each of them is gonna give
you actually a sensation of Aroma right
so they are just might be consumed uh
sugar enhancers or deterrence of liking
but they don't give you a an aroma per
se right an expression if you want to
call it like that so we're being able to
pinpoint and actually there's some
terpenoids in the case of blueberries
are the responsible for some of the
Aromas that we like and we are after in
the breathing process
so with that I sorry I got you longer
than probably uh you were intended to be
sitting there but um I'll I would like
to acknowledge my lab
um because of all the work that we do is
actually uh because of them
and then with that I'll be happy to take
any question if we still have time and
thank you
yes
so
it's very a primary importance because
of shipping
and is it uh sensitive to stage of
ripening and difficult therefore to get
a good measure
yes and yes
um that's the short answer now let me
give you the long answer
so the firmness is important in the
whole process so it's important because
um whenever you pick you know for a
story in that blueberry
for transport in the blueberry you need
it to be firm and then for the child
life into the store and also afterwards
when you're eating the blueberry you
want it still to be firm you know you
don't want it to be smushy or soft right
so that's already been we already have
found out that is very important
characteristic actually didn't talk much
about texture and firmness but that's
the other huge characteristic for us and
yes it's influenced by maturity and then
nowadays up today you know most of the
research has been carrying out with
blueberries that at the maturity stage
but there is a lot more to do in that
area
yes how strong is that
reading reading goal for Fresh Market
versus processing Market
uh we don't do blueberries for process
in our case
um I think probably 90 or 95 percent of
the industry in Florida is or Southern
High bush is for fresh blueberries and
even I didn't mention even using machine
harvesting techniques nowadays so
firmness is important for that too the
highest Fitness is the most important
tree for machine Harvest for fresh
um
there is a big industry for process but
it doesn't pay
so what you find in process is either
blueberries that are
discarded
or
uh the wild blueberries from uh the
northern part of the country and Canada
British Columbia which is low bush is
another species it's this High more or
less it's called a vaccine language
volume and then if you look in videos or
in the internet you're going to see
people raking them from the floor
um those most of those go for uh process
because they don't have firmness
yes have you had any luck predicting
consumer preferences from the Metabolife
profile that's a good question
um
right Vincent
so
we can grab the genomic data to predict
very well
in the volatiles
you know this is the problem of a to B
and B to C but actually uh this Gap in
the middle is not very easy to solve
consumer liking is such a messy data
incredible messy data
and it's mainly because I was just
mentioning this so psychologically
driven uh every single person in this
room are gonna like a probably a
different blueberries if I give you a
bunch of blueberries
um and there is going to be some
Tendencies so nowadays what we do is
that we breathe for the average right
but
it may eventually hopefully we can
breathe for uh the segmentation of the
population and we do have data that is
incredibly messy so we have put 10 years
of data to get some signal out and it
still is messy uh what most of the work
that we do
so we are working with the sensory
people in the university to create you
know more trained panels to give us
better data but at the same time from a
breathing point of view it's like you
don't want them to be too trained right
because you want to breathe for the
population so then there is this
The Academy of what do you do if you go
too much in that direction you have the
expert giving you an opinion is that the
same opinion of the General Public
that's the issue so it's difficult we
have something that is difficult
okay so we have a question from uh
thank you Lee for the question
um
yes on my way here I was just talking to
uh we have a
extension specialist in our group uh it
was assessing everything in the South
and we do have one of our breeding site
affected uh fortunately we have 50 to 60
percent of the foliation only so we're
seeing how we're gonna be assessing that
uh addressing that to make the plans
live again because these are producing
Evergreen production system so it's an
issue because we need those leaves to
stay on until you know may next year
more or less
thank you
we are very good otherwise
question uh
[Music]
uh accumulator blueberry loves uh Asics
soil and so we know Isis aluminum is a
big factor I wonder I mean if the
aluminum has any contribution for like a
stimulant like uh the secondary
metabolized production or what has any
relation so blueberries blueberry needs
acid soil right so that's the first
thing to be vigorous and then to produce
good fruit and of good flavor
um
through the breathing process and in the
program you know I haven't been long
enough to address more advanced
questions uh you think that I think
that's probably the next the next step
we have been trying to address all the
basic if you want to try to implement
tools and then technology into the
program to make it work and then in the
meanwhile to do some research for basic
biology but this is a very interesting
as I mentioned before very interesting
question and then hopefully we can
um we can we can work together if you
see if some of your Gene uh or no
brokers
blocks I mean related to flavor or aroma
aroma I mean there's actually
undermine the aluminary system or under
the recipient I'm very interesting after
discussing with you as well so we will
see what we can do in that in that area
okay so I think uh we are running enough
time so finally we Patricia
thank you
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu